At the weekend I realised I'd left my favourite jumper in the boot of the car,
so I popped down from my flat, joined the queue by the kerb outside,
and waited while a lorry delivered petrol to the station opposite the shopping centre.
On holiday I'd promised my neighbour I'd organise a programme of activities for the children,
including swimming at the local leisure centre, football on the pitch by the metre-high fence,
and a visit to the theatre in the city centre.
Before travelling I wrote a cheque to pay for the jewellery repair,
checked the timetable for the trains,
and practised my presentation for the defence of our proposal at the council.
At half four I bought a packet of crisps and a biscuit from the shop,
threw the rubbish in the bin,
and headed home to tidy the garden before the autumn weather got worse.
Later I booked a table in a cosy restaurant,
made sure the licence for the car was up to date,
and told my mum I'd ring her from the motorway service station on the way back from the hospital.